we can continue you don't need a new
heading but if you like new headings you
can call this applications of
differentiating trigonometric functions
because we are going to take all of this
knowledge that we've been gathering up
we're now going to put it to work so
like I mentioned before these are the
questions in this exercise we're going
to tackle a couple of them and make some
comments as we go through
where did my blue go my blue is gone
here we go so I'm gonna tackle to a and
question six I've modified each of the
questions slightly from what they are in
the textbook so you don't need the
textbook there but this is just so you
know don't do these questions again
okay so now that we know derivatives of
trigonometric functions what can we do
with them lots of things but where we
begin is where calculus began which is
with finding tangents right as soon as
you're like I've got the gradient
function I can know the gradient of this
weird changing curvy thing I can find
the equation of the tangent now we can
do that for trig functions so here is a
very stock standard question I'm going
to walk you through each part hopefully
you'll see how familiar it is even
though there's this new trigonometric
stuff in there we want to find the
equation of the tangent to this curve at
this point tangent to this at that spot
so when you want the equation of a
tangent we have lots of equations of
straight lines which one's going to be
the most useful to you think back all
the way to when you'll find changes last
year which which form is going to be
most useful point gradient form is going
to be the one that's useful because a
tangent is defined by being at a
particular spot that's point and at
exactly the right gradient so it just
touches which of course is what tensions
means right so we need a point we've got
half of it here we need a gradient so
let's work out the point since we've got
this x-coordinate we can pop it into
here so I'm just going to go straight
from here to here but I'm going to
substitute it in y equals cars of two
tons PI out for two times pi and 4 is PI
R 2
sorry that I have too many things
written here pay on - how are you going
and transitioning your brain from
degrees moon into radians if you need to
maybe think oh that's caused 90 degrees
cause of 90 degrees do you remember that
a bit better than cosplay - it should be
zero and if you like you can think about
the graph as well here's the graph right
and you need to become really good at
doing this saying there's two pi that
means there's pi
there's pi on two so there's our value
great so four point gradient form we
have a point there the coordinates so
how do I get the gradient I'm going to
need to come on give me something more
than that you're 12 I'm gonna have to
differentiate the thing you've been
doing this whole time the thing that's
in the heading so help me do that y
equals that so I'm going to write dy on
DX equals alright have a look what rule
are using in this case we're using chain
rule it is a simple version of chain
rule but it is chain rule nonetheless so
I'm gonna go a derivative of the inside
the inside function is 2x so the simple
derivative is 2 now I do the outside
it's cause of something cause of
something that's the one that
differentiates to negative sign so
negative sign and don't forget this is
this 2x is still gonna hang around okay
so I've got that okay I know some people
will see that and say oh the negative is
going to you know it's going to have to
come out the front and I am gonna write
it like that but I just encourage you to
think about your inside and outside one
at a time and don't get them mixed up
students often confuse them together I
have my derivative what I do with this
thing
okay I'm going to substitute in Payan
for pleased obviously this you can't put
this into point created form because
that's not a gradient it's a gradient
function right don't write this but I
see students I see every year someone
will do this multiple people actually
they will do this they will go Y minus
y1 equals and then they say that's the
gradient and then they write this X
minus PI over 4 right and that looks
silly because I'm pointing it out I'm
writing it and telling you not to put
this down but people do this and if
you've got like say a polynomial suppose
like what you had up here with um X
cubed right they'll say oh I know what
the derivative of that is it's 3x
squared so then they'll do something
like this 3x squared and then they will
simplify this and and I just like I just
cried okay so don't do that
this is not a gradient it's the gradient
functions so how do I get the gradient
out of it let's put our value in here we
go when x equals PI on 4 dy r DX is
negative to sign what I did this just
now right sign off PI on to thank you
earn it sine of PI on to how are you
going pink sine of 90 degrees that
should be 1 there's my gradient okay
now I'm ready to go into a point
gradient form I'm just going to write
the first line you guys can take over
and simplify from there it's going to be
Y minus y1
there's the gradient X minus x1
maybe I will simplify it since it's so
simple plus PI on to happy now it's
worth quickly doing this because we're
really quite new to this I wouldn't do
this in the future too many times
because it's time-consuming but just now
it's worth doing a quick check to see is
this reasonable okay so you can see over
here I've drawn this part of the closed
curve but I haven't put any labels on it
so what would I do to make it cause to X
instead of cos x what's the difference
between close to X and cos x I think I
saw the motion right cos 2 X is going to
be up more squashed in instead of one
period every 2 pi you've got two periods
every 2 pi so this is squished in okay
so draw a rough sketch of me over here
the domain will no longer be sorry the
pure will no longer be 2 pi
that'll be PI there so that makes this
pi on 2 which makes this PI on 4 that's
a relief because look that's the
y-coordinate I expected do you see it
it's the x intercept okay
y equals -2 X plus PI on to what would
that look like
-2 X has a gradient that's decreasing
and it's quite steep right well that
looks good that looks good
Fago so you've done your sense check
okay all I would do is just do that in
your head you don't need to draw it but
I just wanted to illustrate it for you
so you know what's going on in my mind
okay